- [Omar] Good afternoon everyone.
Thank you for coming to our Code Talk.
Today we're gonna be talking about
AI agents for cloud operations,
how you could automate
infrastructure management.
One of the key topics we're
gonna discuss today is
also how you could operate
security operations.
And one thing that we're gonna discuss,
the way we formatted today's Code Talk is
we're gonna start off talking
about the core components
of what an agent is, the
type of integrations,
tools, and some fundamental concepts.
From there, we're gonna
jump into the AWS console
and walk through a real demo
and talk through the code and
look at some of the outputs
that come outta this agentic
application that we develop.
So my name is Omar Tabbakha.
I'm a solution architect here at AWS.
- [Shawn] Hi, everybody.
My name is Sean Abdi.
I'm also solutions architect here at AWS.
- [Omar] So before we get started,
by a show of hands,
how many of you have
built out an agent before?
It could be as simple as a
weather application agent.
We have one hand, two hand, okay.
So decent amount of you
have built out agents
within the, my guess is AWS,
maybe some other framework that we use,
but it looks like some of us have
already built out an agent, awesome.
So let's go ahead and get started.
- [Shawn] With that, let's jump right in.
So let's imagine that it's 2:00 AM
and you're a security engineer
that's just been received a call
and now you're thrust into
a high pressure situation
regarding a security incident.
You log in and your first task is
to go through a mountains of
mountains in different logs,
all in different formats,
whether that's JSON
or plaint text,
that could be stuff like VPC
Flow Logs, firewall logs,
API logs, CloudTrail logs,
even third-party vendors
that you might use
for your on-premise or cloud environment.
Nothing native to AWS.
So hours pass by
as you try to piece together
these different fragments,
like I mentioned.
You might have something
like GuardDuty alerts,
CloudTrail logs, DynamoDB logs,
Security Hub findings,
and you're still trying to find out
how all these different
resources talk to each other.
You know, they're from separate systems
speaking a different language
and are really not meant to
communicate with each other.
So the clock is ticking.
You try to identify a suspicious IP,
see if it was really a security incident,
or if it we have a false
positive on our hands
and you've just spent hours and hours
searching, trying to
figure out what's going on.
At this point, you're
starting to get exhausted.
You've done all the grunt work
that something like AI
might be able to handle.
You spent searching
through these resources
with different tools because
they're in different formats
like we mentioned,
whether that's JSON, plain text
or some other standardized schema.
And you're figuring out
what do I need to do now?
So what if we can take this problem
and use some sort of
specialized, intelligent system
like some agents that can comb
through all of these logs,
comb through these different tools
and be able to provide you some insights
that are actionable on your current risk,
giving you more precise
path to tackle this issue.
And that gets us to why AI
for security operations.
So the reality today is
that everything is
moving super fast paced.
Attacks are becoming automated,
people are trying to spend hours
identifying what's going on.
And we just, traditional approaches
with this manual process
just doesn't seem to work
for everybody.
So AI has become the game changer
in the sense that we can now analyze
vast and complex data sets in seconds.
You can detect the patterns and anomalies
that a human might miss for
that error-prone manual process.
And you can automate the repetitive tasks
like triage and log correlation.
And then you use these
surface key insights
to have something to focus on real threats
and not the grunt work that you might see
from a typical security engineer's work
on a day-to-day basis.
So let's start off with
what's a typical LLM
versus agentic AI?
On the left-hand side here, you can see
that we have our usual LLM.
And what this does is
it takes the knowledge
that it's already been trained on,
providing a simple, you
know, concise answer
without doing many iterations
or any thought process or reasoning.
So for example, you ask it the question,
when did the French Revolution take place?
And it'll respond back to
you with the simple answer
of 1789.
Now on the right-hand
side we have agentic AI,
and this is where things get interesting.
The agent is able to think on its own.
So let's go ahead and
check a weather website
for the forecast.
Let's take a look and dive in
and see what the forecast
looks like for the next week.
We've got some rain and it,
but it's also sunny and warm next Friday.
And then we can evaluate and reiterate
until it comes to a proper answer for us
with its reasoning capabilities to say
next Friday is the ideal
day for Mount Fuji hiking.
And the difference here,
again, as I mentioned,
rather than just having a
concise answer on knowledge
that it's already been trained on,
this can think for itself and iterate
until it has a valuable response
that you can use for your triage
or to get further
information from the agent
by asking follow-up prompts.
So the key thing that I wanted to mention
to start us off is like
it's very important
that your data is the key source
for all of this agent building.
You wanna make sure that you
have the right data sources,
that you have everything centralized
in a location that's easy to read,
formatted specifically for
your security use case.
This is where Amazon Security
Lake comes in to play.
For those of you that are not familiar,
this is basically a service that we have
that allows you to centralize
all of those different
tools that I mentioned,
all the different logs,
whether it's JSON, plain text
or something else into a data
lake in your AWS account.
And by doing that,
you're able to normalize
that data from the different schemas
in an easy, ready
available format to read,
which is called OCSF,
the Open Cybersecurity Schema Framework.
And that way, you can use a singular tool
or a singular method of approach
for your log analysis
without having to worry
about these data silos and how they are
disparate to begin with.
Now with that,
I'm gonna go ahead and hand it off to Omar
to do a brief overview of our solution
before we dive into the console.
- [Omar] Awesome, thank
you for that Shawn.
So let's cover our solution, right?
The first thing I wanna talk about today,
we're gonna introduce a
multi-agent application.
So this means we're gonna have
a team of different, specialized agents.
The way I like to introduce this is
think of a team that
you have today, right?
Usually you have a data scientist,
you have a computer scientist,
you might have a sales
team, marketing team,
and each team or person is
specialized in a specific skill
and they're able to come
up with skilled outputs
based on the knowledge they have.
So we take that same exact
paradigm to the agentic world.
For example, in this case
we have this agent, right?
I'm gonna call it subagent
because it's one of the agents
of many that are gonna work together
to help us find the
different security events
and also automate the cloud operations
of remediating those problems.
So this first subagent is gonna be
able to tap into DynamoDB
and pull real business context
from our environment.
Another big one here is gonna be an agent
that's able to use a security lake, right?
Key component here is if
you have servers on premise,
other cloud providers,
maybe you're working with
different SaaS providers as well,
we can centralize, normalize all our data
in a central security data lake
with one specific schema,
and that way our agent can tap in
and access these logs and
provide that information
to the overall system.
Another big one is cloud operations.
Does anyone know here what MCP is?
Has anyone heard that term?
Great, so that stands for
Model Context Protocol.
So a lot of times in today's talk
we're gonna build out custom functions
that you could use as tools.
Again, tools are essentially
APIs or data sources
that our large language models can use
as additional context to provide answers.
And with cloud operations,
we could do different things, right?
We have a cloud control MCP server
that lets you do different
things like, let's say,
add block rules to specific IP addresses
that might be malicious.
Let's say you wanna isolate EC2 instances
or you wanna take forensic snapshots
of your ABS volumes, right?
We could automate our cloud operations.
Obviously, one key concern is, hey,
do we really want to hand the keys
to our production environment to an agent?
That's a big question in everyone's mind.
And that's where we look
into like different things
like guardrails and also implementing
human in the loop, right?
We could actually take a
summary of all the findings
and ask the user, hey, is
this the correct approach?
So like even the best agentic
applications today have
around a low 90% success rate.
So for key, critical operations,
you always wanna have a human in the loop
within that process.
And of course, incident
response playbooks, right?
Some security events might have
nonsensitive data, right?
We're gonna approach those a different way
than in an account that's gonna have
the more highly critical environments.
So here we could have
these agents work together
and we could have a
supervisor agent up front
and this supervisor
agent is going to be able
to use his team of subspecialists
to actually coordinate different tasks
and get different answers
and synthesize them
into a final response.
This could work in two different ways.
The first one could be
approach like an event-driven app,
event-driven architecture
where we could take
GuardDuty findings.
So GuardDuty is our threat service,
our threat detection service.
So we could take GuardDuty findings
and automatically feed
that to our agentic system.
Let's say, for example,
that someone opened
a public S3 bucket, right?
This will trigger some
sort of GuardDuty finding
and send that directly to our agent
and our agent's able to look at that,
understand, okay, what
account was this coming from?
Lemme look at the logs.
Who did this?
How, what steps do I need
to do to remediate this?
And it could do different things
like either raise alerts
to the security teams
that bucket belongs to
based on the business context,
or we could interact
directly with the agent.
So if you want to dive
deeper into the events
or do more advanced things,
we could interact with the agent.
So let's see what that
actually looks like here.
So this is a front-end application
that Shawn and I developed.
We're using a streamlet to
come up with this application.
And the left-hand side
we have example queries
our security engineers could
actually look at and use.
One example here is going to
be the threat detection query.
So here we're saying find
any failed login attempts
exceeding 10 tries in the last hour,
analyze the source IPs
and affected accounts,
and then block the suspicious
IPs and create snapshots.
So this prompt here is
gonna take advantage
of multiple different agents
to complete this task, right?
If we hit submit, we could actually see
that the agent's gonna go like, okay,
let me analyze the authentication logs.
So it's gonna call those specific tools.
So those tools are able to
look at the different tables
we have within our security lake.
It finds CloudTrail events
and Security Hub findings.
It's able to then go ahead and query it
to find what are the source IPs.
Here, it finds three primary source IPs
across different regions.
And then we can execute
our cloud operation agent
that could actually go ahead and block it.
So here you go,
it's showing the different
IPs that are being blocked.
And here it shows the
automated response actions.
So again, this is more
of an automated approach.
One thing you could do is it can give you
the different summaries of what I found.
And then it can ask you,
do you want me to block
these IP addresses?
Do you want me to put
the limited STP controls
within our account?
So again, those are things
that you want to think through.
Some processes, you want to
give full autonomy to the agent,
but other ones that are more critical,
you definitely wanna think
about human in the loop.
And the left-hand side, again,
we have different agents
and we're gonna go
through a few core agents
in the console today
and show you how we actually wrote this.
So the way we developed this is,
let's go to the next slide, okay?
The way we developed this
is using Strands Agents.
This is an open source SDK.
And this is gonna help
you build out agents
with just a few lines of code, right?
It's very intuitive, easy to use.
When I first started looking at agents
and started building
'em around a year ago,
I didn't have my Python,
I haven't done Python since college.
So I was a little rusty,
but with Strands I was able to
pick up very quickly, right?
You're gonna see later
today how it abstracts
a lot of the complexity
of building an agent.
Another core thing is the native tools.
Today we're gonna build the tools,
we're gonna define those Python functions
and make them tools,
but there's also community tools
that you could tap into that already exist
so you don't actually have to code them.
Also easy integrations
with different FCP servers.
AWS has a bunch of different FCP servers
that you could take advantage of today.
And other providers as
well have MCP servers
that you can use.
You could support any
model providers, right?
You're not stuck with just Amazon models.
If you go to Bedrock, we have
over 10 foundation models
that you could use, if you
wanna use OpenAI, Gemini, right?
You're not locked to any sort of provider.
And one thing I wanna talk about is
for these sub-agents,
depending on the task,
we could play around
with the different models
that's powering that specific agent.
So at its core,
what Strands is doing is
it's implementing this agentic loop.
So the way it works is if we look
at the weather application example,
let's say again we want to
check the weather for tomorrow.
Again, the foundation
model has no knowledge
of what the weather's
like next week, right?
It wasn't trained on that kind of data.
So what happens here is the prompt is
going to be sent to the agent
and the agent has access to
the model and the tools, right?
Here in this case, we're
using a react orchestration
where we're actually going to invoke
the model with the user prompt
and the model is gonna
have all the context
around the tools it has access to.
It's gonna be able to do
the reasoning like okay,
I need to get the weather for tomorrow.
Wait, I have these list of different tools
like get weather.
So it's gonna pass that
response back to the agent,
letting it know, hey,
execute the specific tool.
In this case it could be a Python function
that goes to the weather.com API
and grab that weather for tomorrow,
it's gonna return that result
and then send it back to the model.
And this loop is gonna keep on happening
until you get your final response, right?
It could also prompt the user, right?
If some tools require specific inputs
and they're not there,
we could ask the user,
hey, you're asking about
weather for tomorrow,
but I need a state, right?
I can't just give you weather,
weather on what location
you're talking about.
So those are some things
we'll talk about as well.
So just a quick visual on the differences
between using some sort of,
so whether they're using an
SDK like Strands or CrewAI.
As you could see, you go
from 350 lines of code to 55
for a weather app agent.
So for the tool registration,
the conversation management,
API communication,
all that's abstracted away,
it's handled automatically.
And again, when we talk
about when you go through
the Code Talk,
you're gonna see there's
not that many things
you need to define.
Again, our goal is to
simplify creating agents.
Same with the agent loop, right?
Beforehand, I had to build out
the iteration logic manually,
but now I could literally
just call in the agent class
and have it do it for me.
So a process that took four to six hours
can now take 15 to 30 minutes, okay?
So let's go ahead and jump into
the AWS console
and look at our first agent.
Go ahead, Shawn.
- [Shawn] So before we
jump into the console,
I wanted to take a quick
look at the first agent
that we'll be building out
and this is our business
context metadata agent.
So as you can see here,
the agent is going to
ask for an account ID
based off of your AWS account.
That's a 12 digit number that you give it.
You say, tell me about so-and-so account,
our metadata tool that we're gonna attach
to the agent before we instantiate it.
We'll be able to look
through a DynamoDB table
or specific API that you might be using
that holds all of that information.
And the information
that we're talking about
when it comes to business context is
gonna be something like
your business unit,
the criticality,
a point of contact in case
something needs to be reported,
the scope of compliance and so forth.
And we'll take a look
at that in the console
once we open up the DynamoDB table.
But what this allows us to do is
take what most people fail to realize is
that the context and the business context
related to a security incident is
just as important as
the technical details.
You'll be able to sift
through all of these things
within seconds to be able to identify
if this is something that
your team should prioritize
or if you can just leave
it alone, it's low risk,
and maybe come back to it
for a more priority
adverse security incident
that might have already been happening.
So with that, let's go ahead
and jump into the console
and take a look at what
we've got to build out.
- [Omar] Yeah, and real quick,
before we jump in the console
and get to the fun part that
we're all excited about,
I just wanted to see if
there's any questions
on what we discussed,
make sure we handle those questions
before we get into the code.
So does anyone have any
questions about what we discussed
so far around Strands or agents?
Great, okay, awesome.
Let's get right to it.
- [Shawn] Cool, so here
you can see we have
the AWS console, just your
standard landing page.
And what we want to do is
go to Amazon SageMaker AI.
Now we use Amazon SageMaker AI
because there's notebooks
available for us to use.
If you all are familiar with Jupyter,
Jupyter Notebook is an interactive IDE
that's available for you
all to build out your code,
visualize the outputs,
and then experiment in real time.
And this is super helpful as we build out
this agent together in
the room step by step.
So just a quick little
refresher for you all.
Now, the first thing that we want to do
for this agent is install
all the dependencies.
That's things like Bodo 3,
Pandas and other libraries
that you might need.
So we'll go ahead and
install those dependencies.
Once the dependencies are installed,
we're gonna go ahead and use
another import code snippet
right here to get the JSON.
We're gonna import from Strands
the agent and tool functions.
We're also gonna import
Strands models, Bedrock models
that we'll be using for
the sake of this Code Talk.
So we'll go ahead and run that.
And then now we're
getting to the fun part.
So this is where we wanna start off
by making a connection to our data source.
And in this case, we're using DynamoDB.
So we'll create the Bodo 3 session
so that we can interact
with our AWS resources
programmatically.
And we are using DynamoDB
as the data source.
As you can see, the resource is DynamoDB.
We're based outta US East two.
Now for this particular code snippet,
we defined the region
that we're working out of.
There are ways to auto detect that
and you don't have to
hardcode US East two,
you can have it detect whatever
region you're working out of
if you need to.
And we wanna create a metadata table
and define that for
the sake of this agent.
So we're gonna name
that meta_metadata_table
and we are linking that
to a DynamoDB table
that we've already
pre-created in our console.
Yes.
Zoom in a little bit, yeah.
Is that better?
Awesome, so the database that
we currently have set up,
it's called SOC account metadata.
And if we switch back
over to the console, Omar,
and look up, go to DynamoDB,
we can see that all the things
that I was mentioning earlier,
the account ID, the scope of compliance,
the criticality and so forth are
visible right here.
So as you can see, we've
got the account ID,
account name, compliance scope,
and then if we scroll over to
the right a little bit more,
you can see that we have the criticality,
the environment that we're working out of,
determining if it's production,
development and so forth
to help you prioritize
what you want to act on.
So this is just to see
the type of data that we'll be pulling
when we return the business
context using the agent.
Now if we go back to the code,
the first thing we want to do
now that we've connected
to our DynamoDB table is
define the tool.
So we start off with the @tool decorator.
And for those of you that may not be
super familiar with tools,
these are just specialized capabilities
that we give our agent
that allows it to act beyond
its core reasoning abilities.
So in this particular case,
a tool to retrieve account metadata
from an AWS account.
So we'll define that as
get_AWS_account_metadata.
We are giving it the
information instructions
to retrieve metadata about an AWS account
given an account ID.
And the argument that we're giving it is
again, this is an AWS account,
we need metadata for it.
The ID will always be 12 digits.
It's important to distinguish that here
because like I mentioned,
in the case of AWS,
it's a 12-digit account number.
If you put in a number smaller than that,
it'll return results saying
hey, we can't find this account.
So however granular you wanna make that,
we'll find that in the argument.
And then the agent, the
tool is gonna return to us
a dictionary containing
that metadata context
like we just looked at,
the scope of compliance, the account name,
what environment belongs to,
who we should contact and
if we should prioritize this
or maybe move on to something else.
And as you can see here, the response is
gonna be based off of
the account ID string
that we saw in the DynamoDB table.
And we'll get that list
in a dictionary format
once we've instantiated and run the agent.
So let's go ahead and run that code
and now we're ready to
initialize our agent.
So an agent, who can tell me
what an agent consists of?
What are the three components
that make an agent?
No worries.
So an agent is a model,
a system prompt and a tool.
So you can, you maybe notice here
that there's no model
defined here in this agent
and we'll cover that in just a second,
but we'll name the the
agent metadata agent,
we'll give it the system prompt,
"You are a helpful agent
that looks up metadata
about an AWS account
based on the account ID."
Like I mentioned, if the account number is
not 12 digits or it can't find it,
it'll let the user know so
that they can try that again.
And then the tool that
we're giving the agent is
that get_AWS_account_metadata
that we just created up above
in the previous code snippet.
So let's go ahead and
initialize the agent.
And this next piece right here,
as I was mentioning,
we don't have a model defined
and that's because I was perfectly fine
using the default model
that Strands provides us,
which is Claude Sonnet 4.0.
So when we run this model config command,
we can verify that.
Obviously, if you have a specific need
for your use case for a different model,
you're more than welcome to change that
and put the model that you want to use.
Claude Sonnet 4 worked perfectly fine
for this example right here.
So now that we've got all the
necessary resources compiled
and ready to go,
we can go ahead and send
a message to our agent
to get a response with that dictionary.
Tell me about account 67981713.
Maybe we didn't run everything.
- [Omar] Yeah, should we run the blocks?
- [Shawn] There we go.
So if that ever happens, just make sure
you ran all the previous
code snippets beforehand.
And as you can see here,
we've got the account name,
it's Production-Main,
the ID that we gave the
agent in the first place.
You can see the business
unit that it belongs to.
You can also see that it is
a production environment,
critical criticality.
And then if we wanna let
the security contact know,
security@company, and
the incident priority,
for example, highest priority.
This is the type of context
that you might spend
hours trying to gather
from the information
that you have stored
from your data sources.
The agent was able to pull that
in just a matter of seconds
given an account ID.
So with that, I'm gonna
hand it back off to Omar
to show how we use that business context
and how we use the data that
we have for log analysis.
- [Omar] Thank you, Shawn.
So one key thing that I
would like to bring up
when we're talking about agents is
if you're new to building agents,
always start off with a
more simple use case, right?
Something that's a little
more straightforward.
So you could actually
get the hang of defining
different tools, understanding what works
and what doesn't work.
So in this case we start
off with the DynamoDB,
obviously business context agent is,
it is simple but it's also a key component
of our overall architecture.
So let's look at the next agent right here
that we're working on to
build out on the console.
And this one is going to be
the Security Lake agent.
This is definitely a core one here.
So the way this agent's gonna work is
it's gonna use Amazon Athena.
This is going to be a serverless
interactive query service
that actually lets us run SQL Query
directly on all the data sources we have
in our security lake.
So the way this works is
the agent's gonna able to
take a specific prompt,
it's able to convert natural language.
Like for example here,
if you look up at the screen,
we're saying show security group changes
followed by unusual traffic patterns.
So can anyone tell me where do we store
security group changes?
What sort of logs will that be placed in?
Can anyone tell me?
CloudTrail, exactly.
So we have, that's one of the
log sources of CloudTrail.
How about unusual traffic patterns?
VPC Flow Logs, that's right.
So just based on this
natural language query
that we have here, it's
gonna understand, okay,
I need to query,
I need to query the SQL code
to actually query this Security Lake,
pull in any sort of security
group changes that have
unusual traffic patterns.
So this is an example of the
power of the agent by itself.
Down here is sample queries
for multi-agents, right?
So here if we're saying
correlate unusual API activity
with network anomalies and
then contain the threats,
does anyone know what two
agents we need to use for this?
So the first one is how do you
correlate the API activity?
What agent would you need for that?
So hint is we're looking at right now.
What was that?
Yes, so one agent is gonna
be the Security Lake agent
and then for the containing the threats,
if anyone remembers the name of that one.
Let's go back.
- [Audience] Cloud Ops.
- [Shawn] Yes, the Cloud
Ops agent, exactly.
So these two are gonna work together
to actually handle that
query and solve that problem
that we have, okay?
And yeah, let's jump in
into the actual console
and see what this looks like.
You need a drive?
- [Omar] I got it, appreciate it.
So let's go to demo,
okay,
okay, so let's go into the
Security Lake Notebook.
So like Shawn, I'm gonna
install the dependencies.
We're going to then import
different things, right?
The key two things is
gonna be the agent class.
This is what lets us actually define
the agent with the different tools,
foundation model, and prompt.
We're also importing the tool class
so we could actually define
the Python function as a tool.
Sure, zoom in, okay, how's that?
Awesome, okay.
Here I'm just doing some
Security Lake configuration.
I'm giving agent permission to access
my Athena work group that's associated
with my Security Lake.
Again, my Security Lake has
the vlogs across the board
from VPC Flow Logs, Security Hub findings,
and also CloudTrail events.
Here I'm initializing
different AWS clients
so I can actually interact
with Athena, or not me.
The agent can actually
interact with Athena,
Bedrock to actually access
different foundation models.
And then also Glue.
Glue helps us grab the schema information
so we could build that.
So we could actually build the queries.
Here we're defining a Bedrock model.
So I think one of the
strongest points here is
being able to define the
model that you wanna use
for your agent with just one line of code.
So Claude Opus 4.5 probably
came out a week or two ago
and I was able just by changing
one line of code to replace
a different foundation model.
And again, one thing
you want to think of is
depending on the agent and
the complexity of its task,
you might want to adjust which
model you want to use, right?
You wanna think about latency,
you wanna think about cost.
So if we think about the metadata agent,
it's just gonna create a DynamoDB table.
It's a pretty simple task,
there's not much going on there.
So in that case, we could use
a lightweight model
that's faster and cheaper,
like Haiku for example.
Something like this that needs
to look up natural language,
look up schema, create an actual query,
grab the data and then
create the correlations
between activities,
we'd wanna use something
a little more advanced
with more capability.
In that case, we're gonna
use Claude Opus 4.5.
Okay, so now this is,
so now we're gonna actually
define the tools, right?
So now what tools,
does anyone know what sort of tools
my agent would need access to
for the Security Lake agent?
There's no wrong answers.
There's a hint right here.
I'm gonna have to pick someone.
- [Shawn] How do we query the data?
What's the best way to query that?
What was that?
Athena, Athena, yes.
So that's one tool we need.
We need to create a tool for our agents
to actually use Amazon Athena.
And that's what we're doing here.
Here is the context.
So we feed, if you notice a lot of these,
every tool's gonna have
this metadata description.
And that's because we
feed this to the model.
The model knows I have
a tool that can query
the Security Lake using Athena.
And the only argument I need,
I need a SQL query to do this
and this is the returns, right?
I'm gonna return the
results as a string table
or error message if I
don't get anything back
from the Security Lake.
So here I'm just
connecting to Amazon Athena
and I already defined
Athena database up top.
So we're connecting to Athena
and we're actually gonna grab
the unique query execution ID
that belongs to Athena.
And this is just gonna go through
and actually pull in the
results for Amazon Athena.
So that's one tool.
One tool is to actually do the querying.
Can anyone tell me what
the other tool's gonna do?
There's a hint on the screen.
So the second tool is
going to actually list
the tables, right?
'Cause the agent is not gonna know
what sort of data sources I have, right?
So it could be VPC Flow Logs,
it could be CloudTrail Security Hub.
Or if using other third-party providers,
security services,
you could have unique
tables over there as well.
And that's what makes
Security Lake so powerful is
you have one normalized,
standardized data format.
So the agent doesn't have to go in
and really like change up the queries.
It has one unified way of approaching it.
And then finally, we
have get_table_schema.
And this retrieves the schema information
from the Glue Data Catalog
and the agent needs to
grab the schema, right?
It has to look at the column information
and how the data is partitioned,
and based on that it could actually create
queries that can be executed
against Amazon Athena.
So we define the three tools over here,
we're gonna run that.
And now what we're gonna do is
after we define the tool,
we're going to go ahead
and call the agent class
that we have.
And again, for the agent, like Shawn said,
there's three core components.
We need the Bedrock
model that we want to use
or any model, right?
You're not tied to only Bedrock.
If you wanna use OpenAI or
these other foundation models,
feel free to do that.
And then we define the different tools
that this agent has access to.
And I think one very
important component of agents
that a lot of people usually
sleep on is the system prompt.
The system prompt is
essentially the persona,
the personality of the agent.
In this case, we're letting it know
that you're a cybersecurity analyst
with access to an AWS Security Data Lake.
And I give it important database context
and if you notice here, I
also give it a workflow.
The thing is with agent,
it could actually go
through the agentic loop
and figure out the workflow.
But in this case, there is one
good way to actually generate
the actual query.
And that is list the tables, the schema,
and then build queries based on the tape,
the actual data and the schema.
That's one workflow that I define.
And one thing that you wanna
do when you build agents,
you'll notice sometimes
hey, like it's taking
two, three iterations to do something.
I could just tell it in the prompt
that information and we can get rid of
a lot of the latency and extra tokens
that it would usually cost.
And in terms of outputs,
I tell me, gimme specific
remediation steps.
I want data-driven insights
and then key findings with the risk,
the risk assessments.
And that's it.
We defined our Security Lake agents
with its different tools.
And the first prompt that
I want to test out is
what kind of data do I
have in my Security Lake?
So we run that and as you can see,
the first thing it does is
it's gonna list the Security Lake tables.
It realizes we have
three different tables.
So let's get the schema details
so you can get the full picture.
So it runs as you see
three different executions,
one tool call for every single table,
and it grabs that information, right?
It tells us, okay, you
have the CloudTrail events,
which has API activity,
user role and authentication information,
source API calls.
Same with Security Hub findings, right?
It tells you everything
that is usually involved
with these specific findings, right?
Vulnerabilities, remediation
guidance, compliance status.
And the same with VPC Flow Logs.
There we go.
- [Omar] So now that we built
that Security Lake agent,
let's look at how we
could actually build out,
how we could build out
that supervisor agent
so we could use multiple agents together.
So here,
the next step is we have
this log analysis agent
that could actually
generate its own SQL queries
based on the different events coming in
or interaction with the
agent and return results.
And we also have the metadata, right?
So how do we actually set up
these two to work together
in a multi-agent architecture?
So when I first started, we
talked about native tools
that are created by the community.
So two ones that I wanna use
for this specific agent is
gonna be file writes.
This is gonna give our agent the ability
to actually write files to our computer.
Another one is current time.
So if you have specific queries
like tell me about events
that happened yesterday,
this is a native tool.
Again, you don't have to write
any sort of logic for it.
It's already built in and
we just need to import it
from the Strand tools class.
So we'll import those two.
So here, this metadata agent
that Shawn went through was
defined in another notebook.
So I'm just gonna redefine it.
So this specific notebook
has awareness of the agent.
So let's look at how we
actually define multiple tools.
So the way we do this in this example is
we define the agents as tools.
So the supervisor agent,
if we think back to that agentic loop
that SDK operates,
it now has access to different agents
that it can use to complete task.
So in this case, all I'm doing is
I'm defining that Security Lake agent
as one of the tools, right?
The logic was already defined above
in terms of the different tools
it has access to, its persona.
So here I just need to provide the context
so our supervisor agent
knows what has access to.
Same with the get_ AWS_account_metadata,
I'm just gonna define the metadata
and then put some error handling
in case the ID is incorrect.
And then here again,
inputting the agent
class and we're defining
the different tools.
In this case, we have two native tools
that are native to Strands
and we also have two different tools
which are actual agents.
Here again, again, the big
key is the personality,
the persona, which is a system prompt.
When you start building out agents,
that's one thing I highly recommend is
put out the different
prompts and you're gonna see
widely different results.
So in this case, I define
an investigation workflow,
get the metadata, right?
Use the Security Lake agent
to find the findings overview,
get the CloudTrail, network IP analysis.
And then finally, I want
you to generate a report
that gets sent to our security team.
I give it a list of available tools
and then also the output, right?
I want account context, criticality,
account summary,
the risk assessment
based on available data
and also recommended actions.
And if there's any data gaps that require
manual investigation, right?
Sometimes the agent doesn't have
all the necessary context or reasoning
to actually give you some
sort of remediation plan.
So it could tell you
what sort of data gaps
you have within your environment.
So run that
and for when you use different
native tools like file write,
Strand sees it as a sensitive operation
to actually write to your computer.
Usually you'll ask for consent
whether or not you could
write to the computer
in the middle of the invocation.
In this case, right,
agents are autonomous.
We don't want it to stop halfway through
and let us know that hey, could
I invoke this specific tool?
So I'm just gonna run this and just say
bypass any sort of tool consent.
You're allowed to use any tool you want
without human in the loop permission.
So now let's actually use
the SOC orchestrator agent
we just built out.
So we have this account
ID, it's been compromised,
what are the affected resources
actually be concerned about?
So if we run this,
so me and Shawn have
actually been populating
the Security Lake for the
last two, three months
with almost 60 events a minute.
So we have a lot of logs in there
and it's still performing very well
and it's gonna actually go
ahead and start querying
the different data sources,
getting the schema.
This probably takes around
maybe a minute or two
to complete so I'm gonna show you a report
that I generated last night.
So if I come back to home,
look at all my reports, right here,
these are the different
reports I generated.
Let's look at the one from
let's do four hours ago.
So this is the report
that I generated, right?
It's gonna gimme the account ID
and know is based on the business context
that this is a production account.
So it's a highly critical
environment, right?
It's a P1 priority and it's critical
and it gives you a summary.
It says this account has
confidential information
with PCI information with
active compromise, right?
You need immediate containment required.
So it gives you all the context,
the security contact within
that specific AWS account.
Here's the executive summary.
Me and Shawn are definitely in trouble.
We have over 10,000 security
findings within AWS account.
So definitely a lot of work to do there.
Again, we've been
blasting the Security Lake
with a lot of different events
and here it breaks it down, right?
You have 859 critical within S3 buckets.
IAM users, EC2 instances,
security groups that have been modified
and it tells you the risk, right?
Data exposure, IAM user,
there's a credential that's
been compromised and used.
It shows the attack analysis, right?
The source IP, which user is compromised
and also the VPC traffic.
Here we go,
different API operations
that are happening.
People are, that user is
creating security groups,
it's deleting security groups
and it's authorizing specific ports
within existing security groups.
And it actually runs down
through immediate actions
that are required, right?
Rotate all the credentials immediately,
especially the admin IAM,
and it tells you the
things that are critical
that need immediate action,
the short-term actions,
and then some more information
on the compliance impact assessment.
And then let's see if it
generated this report.
So it's still working through,
we can come back here,
but that probably takes
around another minute.
So yeah, let's go ahead and
go to the next slide here.
- [Shawn] So now that
we have our agent code,
we wrote it out, we're
confident it's working,
we tested it within Jupyter Notebooks
and it's doing what we
wanted it to achieve,
the next big question is
how do I run this within
a production environment?
That's one big, key
thing that we're seeing.
And with that, we have
the AgentCore Runtime.
This is a managed service
that came out a few months ago
and it lets you run your agent code,
AI agent code so you don't have to worry
about the underlying infrastructure.
So in this case, again,
similar to Strands, SDK,
any sort of foundation model you want,
whether it's from OpenAI, Gemini,
or one of the handful
of models in Bedrock,
same with framework, right?
You don't have to use Strands
SDK if you're comfortable
with LangGraph, CrewAI,
you're already using them.
You're open to these as well.
So what happens here is, let's say we have
this Python file that I have,
what you could do is you
could either containerize it
in a GACAR file or upload the code as is
to AgentCore and they'll do the packaging
and host it for you.
So what's gonna happen here
is AgentCore Runtime is
gonna create a runtime endpoint.
And this is the endpoint
that was integrated
in that frontend application that I showed
in the beginning of the talk.
It's sending all those
prompts to the endpoint
and the endpoint is
actually able to scale up
the amount of compute resources
based on demand, right?
So when there's a lot of users coming in
and using it during actual incidents,
it's able to scale up and also
scale back down by default.
There's also a lot of cool,
different integrations,
whether that's through identity,
whether you wanna set up observability
and also if you wanna integrate
different MCP servers, right?
We talked about the
cloud control MCP server
to automate cloud operations.
If you haven't checked those MCP servers,
I strongly recommend you do.
It shows you the different range of things
that you can give access to your agents.
Okay, that's it.
So any questions?
Yes.
- [Audience Member] (indistinct).
- [Omar] Yeah, so your question is
you're already using a lot
of these services and tools,
what's the value of
using a security agent?
- [Audience Member]
Basically (indistinct).
- [Omar] Yeah, is it automated currently?
Okay.
- [Shawn] Yeah, so I guess
the complexity of setting up
the automation in terms
of are you automating
remediation security findings?
- [Audience Member] (indistinct).
- [Shawn] Yeah, no, it's
definitely a good concern.
If you want, let's connect after.
I'm curious to explore
more about the tools,
what you're doing and
then how this would fit
in the overall.
There's some questions I wanna ask you.
Yeah, appreciate the question.
Any other questions?
Yes.
- [Audience Member] (indistinct).
- [Shawn] Yeah, for
registry specification,
is this related to registering tools
or what is this relate to?
- [Omar] Are you currently using that?
Are you currently doing a
registry for your for setup?
- [Audience Member] It's my headache
because trying to allow
authentication to the agent,
let's say we might (indistinct).
- [Omar] Yeah.
- [Audience Member] And I
think we need have a unified
(indistinct).
- [Omar] Yeah, so I know with AgentCore,
it's not in this specific slide,
but there's also a core component,
a future called AgentCore Identity.
And that's one thing where we could unify
the different access and authentication
for our agents within that area.
And if you want, we
could, I could dive deeper
after the talk about how that
works at a higher level, yeah.
Yes.
We'll go this way and then
we'll come back to you.
- [Audience Member] So in
the cloud (indistinct).
- [Omar] So is it more of,
is ensuring that the agent is up to date
with your infrastructure environment?
Like your Terraform.
- [Audience Member] Like
just for like, I guess
a naive example like
let's say a (indistinct)
or some environment sitting
in a Terraform configuration
somewhere in a natural workflow,
like totally separate thing.
And then there's an event (indistinct).
- [Omar] Oh, I see what you're saying.
- [Audience Member]
Configuration reflects reality.
How should I think about
that in this environment
where an agent is potentially
making 10 changes,
dozens of changes a day?
- [Omar] Yeah, yeah, and
that's one thing I recommend
for production environment changes
at the current state of
agents and how they operate.
That's one thing where we
would look at implementing
the human in the loop where
look at the different changes,
recommendations and then
you implementing them
manually yourself within the environment.
- [Shawn] There's still some
necessity for human in the loop
when it comes to that
'cause you don't want
automated remediation
happening behind your back,
you know what I mean?
And then you have to go reconcile that.
- [Omar] Yeah, yeah, we're getting there.
Hopefully the, maybe next
year you could automate
the whole stack.
But as of now, we take
those recommendations
of what changes need to be made
and you could actually feed
the Terraform code to you.
So you could have the Terraform code,
you could review it and then feed it
and upload it to your main code repository
and then sync that.
- [Audience Member] Perfect, all right.
Can you have the agent, you know,
run through the same (indistinct)?
- [Shawn] You could.
- [Audience Member] Then
you wouldn't have any drift
because the agent would be, you know,
using Terraform in the same way
that you are using Terraform, right?
- [Shawn] Exactly, yeah.
So you could have a, let's say
part of the overall solution,
you could have an agent
that specifically is
working to developing and working with
that specific environment.
So that's true, that's
also another option, yeah.
- [Omar] Had a question over here.
- [Audience Member] Yeah, (indistinct).
- [Shawn] Into Security Lake?
Or with other sources
besides Security Lake?
I'd have to double check on that.
Let me talk with you afterwards to see
what other sources that
you might be trying to use.
I know that most of those resources,
people have been centralizing
them within Security Lake,
but is there a reason why you
want to keep them separate
from Security Lake?
- [Audience Member] (indistinct).
- [Shawn] I'm sorry?
- [Shawn] Gotcha, I'd have
to double check on that one
for you and I'll get back to you on it.
Yeah, did you have
something to say on that?
- [Omar] No, I'll talk to
him after, I couldn't hear.
- [Audience Member] So just
to summarize at this time,
should we say that this technically
monitor for information?
- [Shawn] Yeah, I'd say at this time it's
more of not only monitoring
but also doing the correlation for you.
Like for example, jumping between
the different data sources,
running the SQL queries
and actually looking at the correlations
between this specific
security group being deleted,
tied to specific IPs.
So a lot of that grunt work of doing
that manual process
definitely could be automated.
And even the,
in terms of like actually automating
the infrastructure as
code and deploying things,
that's something that
the Claude MCP server
actually has access to, right?
It could write Terraform for you
and actually execute it and run it.
But again, back to the
point of at this time,
like you were saying,
I wouldn't feel confident
enough with agents
to actually perform production changes
without me actually
looking at what it's doing.
Awesome, should we, let's
go ahead and wrap it up.
- [Omar] Let's wrap it up, yeah.
- [Shawn] So hopefully
some of that was useful,
you know, to the people in the room,
and on the left-hand side we have
our Strands Getting Started.
You know, this is all of the
documentation and everything
you'll need to build an
experiment with Strands
if you'd like to test
something like this out
in your own environment,
highly recommend getting
hands on and doing so.
And if you're also
interested in deploying,
you know, Strands Agents
to the Amazon Bedrock,
AgentCore Runtime,
please scan the QR code
on the right-hand side.
This gives you the
operationalized capabilities
to test this in your own AWS environment.
Everything that you need to
get started is right there.
And then one last thing I
wanna leave you all with.
If you haven't heard of
SkillBuilder.AWS yet,
whether you're new to
the cloud or new to AWS
or just want to get some hands-on,
more hands-on experience
to enable yourself,
we've got thousands of free,
different learning resources,
hands-on labs, immersive,
real-life situations
where you can get that experience
to build these things out.
If you're pursuing an AWS certification
and need some extra
tools to study for that,
we also have that available on our site.
And if you need to validate
some practical skills
for some micro-credentials,
whether that's for
yourself or for your team,
if you need that, that's also available
on AWS Skill Builder.
So with that, we'd like
to thank you all so much
for joining us today and
if you have any questions,
thank you.
(audience applauds)
And great job, Omar.
If you have any questions, we'll be here
for the next 10 minutes.
Please feel free to come by.
We'd love to chat with you.
If we didn't get to one of your questions,
mentioned we wanna talk to
you, please stick around.
We'd love to chat.
Hope you all enjoy the rest of re:Invent.
Thank you.
- [Omar] Thank you.